so I've been thinking a lot about this
idea of biology as something with almost
the kind of agency right a kind of
directionality you know not to get
metaphysical here but you could actually
think of the 10 trillion cells that
self-organized and collaborate to become
the meta organism that is a human being
means that biology seems to exhibit a
kind of protoplasmic yearning a desire
to self-organize there seems to be
conditions in this universe that
engender novelty complexity sprouts mind
emerges from matter and then starts to
manipulate matter at the level of the
atom with nanotechnology it's like it's
a human being seem to be the cutting
edge the evolutionary pinnacle of
self-awareness becoming aware of its
becoming right it's almost like like the
birth of mind folds the attention back
and looks at its own heritage and starts
to put itself into context the universe
comes to know itself through human
beings we've decommissioned natural
selection Edward o Wilson says and now
we must look deep within ourselves and
decide what we wish to be
you